after the attack on the White House it
was discovered that a number of Key
Personnel had been captured throughout
the city one of these people included
keenly college student Eva Garcia but
why did she find her treatment as a
captive of the Black Tusk so pleasant
[Music]
Eva Garcia a history major at Kinley
College returned to campus after a
Thanksgiving spent with her family
alongside her studies Eva ran a podcast
where she spoke about whatever was on
her mind with the side objective of
gaining extra credit
after the outbreak Kinley College faced
a drastic change as the school closed
its doors due to the escalating crisis
the effects of the outbreak quickly
became apparent as students and faculty
started falling ill
Eva caught in the midst of the chaos
Bantu dormitory transformed into a
makeshift quarantine facility the
overwhelmed Health Care could no longer
handle the growing number of six
students
with no other choice Eva made the
difficult decision to leave keenly
college and head back to her home in
Florida
leaving behind the safety of the college
either found herself on a dubious ride
towards Washington DC she made the
decision to exit the vehicle and seek
alternative means of getting back to her
family
I don't even know if you're getting
these but I wanted to let you know we
left Kelly I'm on my way
it just might take me a little longer
than expected
Chad was while he was Chad and I knew I
shouldn't have gotten in his car but it
was that or wait for a Sarah evacuation
bus
Chad seemed like the safer option I'm
okay
he tried some stupid but I'm okay
we were outside of Baltimore so I'm just
gonna head down 95 until I can get
another ride or get home to you
whichever comes first
mom does she got this
make me posole
eventually Eva would have to abandon her
Long Walk Home the weather was getting
too much to handle so she decided to
wait it out until spring with a local
community she stumbled across
thought it was supposed to get warmer
the further south he went but this
winter is like extra cold and snowy
maybe in the spring I can start walking
again but for now I found this group and
I think it's smarter if I stay with them
for a while
they set up a community in an apartment
complex outside of DC they've got plenty
of food and there's even some people
talking about building rooftop gardens
and raising chickens in the spring
if they can find some chickens
I hope you're getting these
I'm a little worried that you haven't
called me back
and now your phone is going straight to
voicemail
mom
call me back okay
I love you
from the division recruited novel we
learned that the settlement or Community
called Athena was a village in the
hollowed out remnants of the city
the building had once been luxury condos
inhabited by the wealthy when the dust
had settled a group of survivors had
gathered there determined to make the
best of it
the concentration of almost 40 families
was no accident they huddled together
for safety
in the wake of the viral apocalypse the
most dangerous thing left in the world
was other people
Myra recruited's protagonist was pushed
into the role of Athena's head of
community security and whether she
wanted it or not she was the best person
for the job
however over time the position had
forced her to make some calls that
rubbed people the wrong way and in some
cases led to a loss of life
hey Mom you didn't call me back kind of
just hoping you forgot to charge your
phone or the local Tower is out or you
know cell phones don't work in Florida
anymore but in case you're still worried
about me I just wanted to let you know
I'm good
Athena is a pretty chill place we get
attacked every once in a while but we've
got food and Myers making sure we're
safe and I even made a friend her little
brother Kazi
don't worry it's not romantic or
anything we're just friends
he's barely 18 so yeah a little young
for me
don't worry Mom although it could help
pass the time there's no danger of me
getting knocked out by some kid while I
wait out the Apocalypse in Maryland love
you call me back
as we would find out later on in the
story it wouldn't remain happy and
peaceful at Athena for very long
Athena would come under attack by the
outcasts although Myra had put many
hours into preparing the community for
this very event it was just too many of
them
however just before their last lines of
Defense would fall the sudden appearance
of division agents came to their rescue
Tina would survive another day but the
community was looking a little worse for
wear with a number of casualties
Myra having done the absolute best that
she could with what she had at hand was
praised for the leader of the division
cell
but upon learning of their mission to
find out why Supply shipments weren't
making it through and if fixed how this
could help the community Mayra asked to
join them provided that Athena would be
cared for
hey Mom
pretty sure you'll never get this but if
you do I wanted to let you know we're
moving
guess you shouldn't believe everything
people say about the division
some agents saved Athena last week lost
one of their own in the fight and Myra
joined them on some secret mission
between losing her and the
damage to the complex and with winter
coming it's really not smart for us to
stay here anymore
honestly it hasn't been the same since
qazi died
true Sons got him
anyway the division offered to take us
in
a sent a group to move us to the castle
I don't know if that's code or if we're
like really moving into a castle but
yeah if you ever get your phone working
again and check your voicemail you can
find me at the castle
I miss you Mom love you
hope you are dead
sorry Mom sorry
call me back okay
I love you
bye
eventually the jtf would take Eva and a
number of the remaining Athena Sizzlers
to the recently reopened Castle
settlement over time many would assist
either for job placement to fund the
perfect fit for how she could do her
part in the running of this new
community you'll eventually learn of a
media background and ask if she would
like to get the settlement radio back up
and running to play music make
announcements and overall boost morale
degrees
but it wasn't so long after this time
that Eva along with a number of other
Personnel were forcibly abducted by the
Black Tusk
agents receive Intelligence on either's
possible location at the Eclipse fuel
Depot and quickly mobilized to clear the
area of hostile true sons and secure The
Outpost
however this search proves fruitless as
either as nowhere to be found
frustration mounts as the agents regroup
but many interrupts the disappointment
with urgent news he announces a huge
surge of Black Tusk activity at the
Department of Justice raising the
possibility of finding leads on Eva's
whereabouts the agents redirect their
focus and set off towards the Department
of Justice
agents proceed maneuvering through the
courtyard and engaging in combat with
the true Sons
they would make their way through to the
underground car park
finally they come face to face with a
high value Target
after dispatching the Hostile leader the
agents would discover a crucial clue a
piece of abandoned communication
equipment that points to either's
possible whereabouts
the urgency of the situation intensifies
as they realize she may be at the Navy
Plaza
hostile radio
another stop on the worst tour of the
city like maybe pause is cool I guess
but unless you really like military
history or like a true patriot or some
it's just like a paintless
flagpoles
agent gets a Navy Plaza
agents swiftly Converge on the compound
the true sons have fortified the area
that the agents undeterred navigate the
barricades and overcome wave after wave
of hostile forces
their perseverance pays off as they
successfully neutralize two prominent
leaders within the true Sun's ranks
amid the chaos of battle another
communication from Eva has discovered it
becomes evident that she is deliberately
leaving behind hints and breadcrumbs
leading the agents closer to her
location
with this new information the agents
follow Eva's Trail and fight on to
ensure his safe return
it's like being back in the library
it's more boring and with less people
where the hell are you taking me
you're closing in on them Eve is at the
National Archives
agents confront Fierce resistance from
the true Sons upon arriving at the
entrance of the National Archive
Building
they navigate the structure eliminating
hostiles and definitely not getting lost
again
eventually they would face off against a
true Sun leader once eliminated Manny's
voice would once again be heard of the
earpieces
wasting no time he announces the
discovery of Eva's whereabouts
she's at the Viewpoint Museum
the true sons have fortified the
facility posing a formidable challenge
for the agents
with unwavering determination they fight
their way through the heavily guarded
entrance
as they delve deeper into the facility
waves of enemies grow in size and
intensity until eventually they come
face to face with another rogue agent
however the Agents come prepared armed
with their shooting lightning gun that
swiftly dispatches the Rogue
pressing forward they reach the
broadcasting area where the true Sons
make their final stand
among them Lieutenant Thompson stands as
their final challenge
but while all of this is playing out the
jtf arrives mounting a successful rescue
operation to secure Eva Garcia and bring
it back to the safety of the castle
settlement
once Eva was safely back at the castle
sediment many were Chicken on her
favor
what does she make you do hello
I'm not oh she didn't really make me do
anything like she wanted me to record
some radio show to entertain the troops
but it wasn't a big deal or anything
you don't think that's weird
not really you asked me to do the same
thing yeah
but how did she know that you're a DJ
well she said she liked my podcast well
sorry I never got the extra credit since
the school sort of died
Natalia listened to your podcast
what else did she tell you
nothing really
played me some Isaac recordings tried to
get me to use them on the show
uh Manny you might want to stop taking
your comms to bed the black tasks know
like way too much about your sex life
dude
everything was all good she even
referred to Natalya as net like they
were close friends now Natalia even said
that she used to listen to a podcast at
keenly College
she wanted either to record a radio show
to entertain the troops sort of a morel
boosting thing and Eva pointed out that
this isn't so much different to what
many wants her to do
but she did say that Natalia asked her
to play some Isaac recordings on her
show
maybe this was to be used as a
propaganda piece
the blacktest soldiers have been
fighting for a few months now perhaps
this was to pick them up and remind them
what they're fighting for
the future of the country and to get
there they need to remove that Rogue
operation calling themselves the
division
so once again we're hearing that the
Target that was supposedly being held
captive was actually well cared for by
the Black Tusk
so with the Black Tusk actually the good
guys
no I'm not going to humor this for even
one second
the amount of crap they have pulled over
the previous months 100 says otherwise
this is just a ploy to gain more support
for this side
if you were going to take over the
country and label yourself as the
legitimate savior you'd have an easier
time with the support of more than just
the military under your employment
you want the community leaders the
voices the ones going above and beyond
to rebuild Society
with that support behind you there would
be few that wouldn't have a hard time
fighting against you
Natalia is using a new tactic attacking
the division head-on has proven
ineffective time and time again
now she's going after the one thing that
the division needs to survive more than
anything else
support of society the vulnerable the
innocent
without them there really isn't too much
more they have to fight for
the government is gone the
infrastructure is more or less obsolete
in most major cities that we are aware
of
Society was the last thing that the
division was fighting for and if they
have already chosen which side is the
right side what more use are the
division to the people of the US
fortunately even the most recently
rescued civilian Eva Garcia doesn't
believe a word Natalia is saying
kindness how cool is that in the
face of unspeakable speakable certain
death
of chaos demons chose to dig into their
trauma and be nice to people
don't fall for that this is like
day one of fascism 101 do you want
apartheid or indentured servitude
because that's how you get apartheid and
indentured servants
foreign
so this was a great Target to be
rescuing I personally loved Eva's
recordings at Kinley College not
necessarily for the content of what she
was saying but more for the intelligent
yet super sassy way of presenting it I
actually felt a bit of the writer's
personality coming out in this character
this time around and I told Lauren that
although I'm not sure she actually
appreciated it I meant it in the nicest
possible way I'm actually really glad
that Eva has been brought in and I hope
that we hear more from her over the
seasons her youthful itchiness is
appreciated and a nice contrast to some
of the other characters I mean they said
in the John yezzy rescue that he was
good for her but I think it's the other
way around he is such a downer hopefully
she'll be able to help him move on
however the next time you're close to
the propaganda open world activities
after you capture it have a listen
this is your new favorite DJ Eva Garcia
the mouth from the south
that's a terrible catchphrase forget I
said that
so
Manny vetoed my come for the fish taco
stay for the company slogan idea said
people might think it's perverted or
something
like some of the most beautiful people
have done the most horrific things and
we excuse their shitty ass Behavior
because we want to them
and now we think about that or like
horrified that's the same with Matt
like she's hot so you want to smash and
then excuse the fact that she like
indiscriminately murders people every
day and then says join us we are here to
protect you
I've sat around recording for like 30
minutes and I'm still hearing you once
because they don't seem to play in a
sequence they all seem to be random
also this target came with another
Crossover with a recruited novel and I
feel like this was the largest crossover
we've had yet
evil was in the Athena settlement at the
same time as Myra and she knew her
I actually went back and read the first
three chapters again just to make sure
there wasn't any reference to Eva
because you know that would have blown
my mind
if I hadn't already said it I'm really
liking how these new seasons are playing
out not just the gameplay but also the
story behind some of the new slash not
so new characters I feel like we're
learning a lot more about them and
getting a far clearer gauge on what
they're about and how they will
influence the community going forward
I guess it also helps that we are just
killing them at the end of each Mission
too
anyway I think that will do it for now
thank you once again for watching and
extremist malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]